as a start-up and learning all this
great data within Google Analytics I
think the best advice I would say and
stick with it it's a lot of information
and I think a lot people think it's a
little daunting because they don't know
where to get started what's really great
is that we have a lot of amazing
tutorials online there's actually a
video overview that kind of talk walks
in through the different steps talks
about someone who's a bit more you know
it has implemented and it may be used a
little bit more further than like a
brand new startup can give them all the
tips and tricks to be successful so I
think the best advice is to keep at it
and don't give up and you know make sure
that you can get help along the way